I just hit me like I had an epiphany at
the very least I'm gonna be beating a
dead horse here there were nothing else
you've probably heard all of it over and
over and over again on YouTube but the
perfect comparison it just came to me
and when it did I was like gotta do a
video on it cuz it's kind of what I do
what I know to do I first of all that is
a spoiler warning if you're not caught
up on Game of Thrones let's talk about
some [ __ ] from the last episode again
what have you been on social media in
the past couple days you probably
already had it spoiled for us or
whatever and this video was brought to
you by me cuz this one's from me
writes of Daenerys Targaryen she's
Anakin Skywalker like in every sense of
the word his plan that she would go bad
from the beginning check foreshadowing
of that turn along the way check right
up until they turn she seems like a good
person check and at the drop of a
[ __ ] hat willing to kill children
check Anakin Skywalker like to the
letter some people in the comment
section are apparently under the
impression that I hate that she turned
bad no it's not that
it is the execution the most common
counter example is that there was
foreshadowing along the way check
foreshadowing is not character
development
just because you foreshadow that
something's going to happen doesn't mean
you've taken the audience and the
character together on a journey in which
the audience is gonna buy that and just
like Anakin Skywalker's and there is
turning bad I mean looking forward to
that we were all looking forward to
seeing Anakin turn bad and since about
season two or three when people started
naming their kids after Daenerys I was
like I'll please let her go bad that
could have been the greatest flip in
television history not only did I want
to see the doughy I'd look in the
children's faces when they look at their
parents like you know you named after
your uncle Danny who you've never met
you know what go play with your cat
Danny [ __ ] how do you rename your kid
but I thought turning Daenerys into a
villain that could have been awesome but
you had to take you take some time to do
that you know this was really like
Anakin Anakin goes from I'm gonna turn
you over to the Jedi Council chance
15 minutes later yeah I guess I will
kill kids with Game of Thrones we go
from sir Davos being like what if
Westeros was ruled by a good woman and a
good man oh yeah she's good and she
looks like she's kids
well that was abrupt about as abrupt as
anakin's turn it's a shame it's a bummer
because there is if I'm gonna reference
the movie Armageddon
you know Armageddon had
line and when the meteor was past the
line it was like that's the point of no
return we can't do anything now
character arcs are very much the same
way it's kinda like right after the
force awakens I thought the best arc
they could do with Ray's turn her back
but then after the last Jedi she ends
the last Jedi being so good like good
straight arrow straight edge boring hero
good that her flip into the dark side in
Episode nine just wouldn't make any
sense at all and a throwaway for shadow
line of Luke Skywalker talking about you
went to the darkness you didn't even
fight it from the last Jedi wouldn't be
enough for me to buy her going bad in
Episode nine if they do it which I don't
think they will because again they're
past the Armageddon meteorite line
threshold thing anyhow today I realized
it Anakin Skywalker's flip and Daenerys
is flip they so parallel each other
right down to the bad writing of them
that I just I don't buy either of them
and in both cases I guess if I read the
books I guess I'll get it more like I
guess it was this Targaryen book if I
read it I'll understand
I shouldn't have to you shouldn't have
to go outside the movies to understand
Star Wars I shouldn't have to go outside
the show to understand Game of Thrones
and it will say I want to emphasize this
isn't to get down on anyone who does by
her flipping to villainy cuz there are
people who totally bought Anakin
Skywalker's flip they didn't think it
was too abrupt but whatever people
that's life people don't see things how
other people see things we all see
things differently but this is just how
I see it I see Daenerys his turn like
Anakin's turn and I didn't like how
abruptly anakin skywalker turned to the
dark side and I don't like how abruptly
Daenerys turned to the dark side so when
that hit me had to do a video on it so
here you go we just also me saying my
last Game of Thrones video might have
pissed off some Game of Thrones fans
this might piss off some Game of Thrones
fans and some Star Wars prequel this one
is if you like this video if you give
this video a like that would probably
help me out of it I would appreciate
that so Daenerys turning to the dark
side of the force like Anakin do you see
it how I see it do you see it
differently do you like Daenerys has
turned to you not like Anakin Stern
do you like Anakin's turn do you not
like Daenerys his turn whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]